I'm excited for fans to get to see this
giant four-hour movie that's completely
singular to their investment if you followed
the first two movies this movie really kind of
takes you into a completely immersive scope and scale
the fan community has sort of risen up demanding
this version well because of the promise
i've made them over the course of the two
other movies it has created this movement
that said we need to know how it ends
and then being able to shoot an additional scene
for justice league and it was fun to do and it's
fun to get ben back in the cowl he looks as good
as ever in that cowl i was like we never stopped
you still think it was a good idea
bringing him along what do you think
in any endeavor to be supported is an incredible
thing you know especially supported by this
incredible fan base they've really taken the
movie to heart and so there is something really
satisfying and fun for me bringing these
amazing fans a movie that they wanted to see
there's an attack coming it's already here
this really blows out to a much larger
mythological version of the movie these
epic set pieces one after another i'm putting
together a team people with special abilities
it's a really epic gods fighting gods scale so
that's what i'm excited for fans to get to see
they will stumble
they will fall
they will join you in the sun Kal
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
justice league snyder cut documentary movie video
as well as them talking about how the snyder
vs movies the justice league snyder cut sort
of fits into the canon of the future dc movies and
what their plan is for making this all make sense
because we have all these new versions of batman
that are coming into the universe between michael
keaton's batman and robert pattinson's batman and
then you have all the other new characters like
supergirl coming in so how do you explain all
these characters going forward so if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos and obviously careful for spoilers from the
snyder cut if you have not seen it yet but they
just recently released this short documentary
movie on the making of the justice league snyder
cut with the cast the footage of them filming
the additional photography like you actually see
them with batman joker deathstroke filming the new
nightmare flash forward scenes for the epilogue
he talks about why the movie wound up being so
big why it's four hours long why he decided to do
it in the first place like he wanted to pay off
his snyder vs storyline give fans a chance to
experience some kind of closure in an ending
of sorts even though yes it does end on a
massive massive cliffhanger he said that he
did that on purpose like he wanted to pay
off his story and he does have the sequel
stories mapped out in great detail so i'll
explain what he said about those as well
he also said that because of the circumstances
behind the movie's release like the reason why
it exists in the first place he wanted to make it
the most version of justice league that he could
in his own words he refers to it very fondly as an
exercise in pure indulgence like hey we're doing
this for fun and he really did just do it for
fun because he was not getting paid by warner
brothers to make it now there was a lot of money
that they spent on at upwards of like 70 million
dollars but all that went to like the big expenses
like visual effects the editing and all the lesser
people that worked on it zack snyder himself
did not take any pay to work on the snyder cut
but as he said that exercise in pure indulgence
that's why some of the scenes seem like they go
on for so long why there's so much slow-mo and why
the ending of the movie with the epilogue attached
is like a whole 30 minutes all by itself
it's almost like a short film by itself
just tagged onto the end of the film is also the
reason why he added the jared leto joker stuff
when originally joker was never supposed to be in
his original version of the justice league film
like he wanted to pay off this moment between
batman and joker that he didn't think that he
would ever be able to do in future movies which
is where he would have eventually paid this story
off between them and the dead robin the rest of
the cast also talk about working with zack snyder
but a lot of the interview footage especially with
say like henry cavill is from a couple years ago
when they were originally working on the first
cut of the film most of the work that he did to
make the snyder cut was actually just finishing
special effects visual effects and editing on the
mountain of footage that he'd already filmed back
in 2016 and 2017 before he left the project there
was only a tiny bit of additional photography
that they did last year like the joker scene
that you see them filming here but right now what
zack snyder has said the studio basically told
him when they green lit the snyder cut that they
were considering it a one-off thing like this is
it for you like they didn't make him any promises
that he'd ever get to make those sequels and he's
been talking about the sequel stories himself a
lot the past couple of weeks in his interviews
saying that of course he'd love to make them but
he'll believe that it's going to happen when the
studio calls them like put up or shut up like i'll
believe it when i see it sarcastically he also
said that originally when things went sideways a
couple years ago because he and jim lee spent so
much time mapping out and drawing storyboards for
the justice league 2 and justice league 3 movies
they were gonna finish the story of the sequels in
a comic book series he said he also planned to do
a prequel story in a comic book for batman and
jared leto's joker that would show off the full
story for what happened with the dead robin you'd
see zack snyder's version of a death in the family
story but the whole reason why you haven't seen
those justice league 2 and justice league 3 comic
books yet is because of the at t buyout when they
bought time warner which includes warner brothers
zack snyder said the comic book project fell
through like it got cancelled in the mix but
now a couple years later if there was enough fan
interest they could probably get that going again
so it sounds like that's more likely to happen the
new warner brothers ceo also just reiterated today
in a brand new interview how she considers the
justice league snyder cut the final zack snyder
movie like we really wanted him to be able to tell
his story but they're being very non-committal
about bringing zack snyder back to work on future
dc films never say never though it's always
possible that he comes back to do some different
sort of hbo max series like even if they don't
bring him back to do another dc movie he could
do some separate hbo max series in the future
right now the warner brothers does have plans to
eventually make more justice league movies but
here's what the current plan is just in terms of
how the snyder cut will fit into the canon going
forward with all the different batman versions the
new version of supergirl all the other dc movies
that they have playing right now currently warner
brothers is treating the snyder vs movies like man
of steel batman v superman and justice league is
the main earth of the dc eu that's not going to
change most of those characters are going to come
back and direct sequel movies to their spin-offs
like aquaman 2 wonder woman 3 the flash movie
but here's where we splinter off into multiverse
territory warner brothers is treating the end
of justice league here like when they defeat
steppenwolf kill him as the actual end of the
movie the conclusion of the justice league story
like it's over they're sort of pretending like
the nightmare scene epilogue only happens in an
alternate universe so the story of zack snyder
sequels like the actual stories that he has with
the nightmare movie and justice league 2 and then
all the time travel stuff with justice league 3
that happens in an alternate universe in the main
timeline then you go forward from this moment
where they defeat steppenwolf to the events of
the aquaman movie the flash movie the shazam movie
black adam pretty much every other dc movie that's
coming up except for robert pattinson's batman
movie and the new superman movie that they just
announced which is rumored to be a valzod movie
the batman movie per matt reeves is set in
its own universe it's like its own bubble
of continuity it also takes place pretty close to
present day in the timeline so that's how they're
explaining why batman looks 20 years younger all
of a sudden but somehow it's still present day
pretty much every other upcoming dc movie though
still set in that main pre-nightmare snyder-verse
version of earth the only major question that they
haven't clarified yet is supergirl will she come
from the main snyder vs earth and just show up
like hey i just arrived now my pod just showed up
zack snyder did tease a version of supergirl a
long time ago but it was really twisty the way
they incorporated that into the events of the man
of steel movie or will her new character just come
from a totally different earth of the multiverse
she's gonna appear in the flash movie it's a
multiverse movie so it's pretty easy to explain
how she comes from an alternate universe but i
think the idea is to make her a relatively simple
character to understand they don't want to get too
crazy with it then what they're going to do with
ben affleck's batman and henry cavill superman
going forward is they're bringing ben affleck's
batman back for at least one last big crossover
movie in the flash movie he'll be giving the
flash's new multiverse time travel suit that they
showed off in the flash movie teaser and after
that i think him coming back just depends on the
right kind of story or cameo scene never say never
but the way warner brothers has been hinting at it
they plan on the new crossover version of batman
and future movies to either be michael keaton's
batman or robert pattinson's batman and they just
come from the multiverse anytime they need a big
team up the whole plan for henry cavill as far
as we know right now is that he's still working
on a series of cameo appearances in future dc
movies but not a direct man of steel 2 sequel
movie because apparently they just announced
the val zod spin-off superman movie and just
for reference james gunn also said that when he
was doing his suicide squad movie warner brothers
told him he could pretty much use any characters
he wanted with no restrictions like literally any
characters he wanted so it sounds like they're
leaving character choices people coming back
completely up to each new director when they come
in to do new movies so henry cavill the other zack
snyder characters like deathstroke for instance
them coming back is completely in the hands of
future movie directors and just for reference
we are supposed to get that first suicide squad
trailer sometime in the next couple of months
the movie will be coming to hbo max in august
i will do a full video for zack snyder's story
for justice league 2 and justice league 3 later
this week he did basically reveal the entire story
of the sequel so we know what was going to happen
my falcon and winter soldier episode 2 video will
also post on friday just like normal so while
you wait for everything click here for that full
justice league snyder cut ending scene in the end
credits and click here for my full justice league
snyder cut breakdown video and easter eggs for
the entire movie thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!